hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm wanted to make a
quick video i know if you're watching
this you probably watched most of my
videos that i have but i did want to
point out that there are a lot of great
chess channels out there hopefully you
are learning a ton for my videos but you
know if you're just a fan of chess and
you just want to learn more about chess
there are some fantastic chest channels
out there that some are kind of old as
you may be a oh yeah you know I've
watched all those videos some may be
fairly new that you may not be familiar
with so I'm gonna be going over for
today that I actually really enjoy
watching if you have others if you just
started up your own chess channel or
you've been watching one for a while
that you just think is fantastic feel
free to leave a comment and post and let
people know I definitely want this to be
a place where people can confine great
chess content and just fall in love with
the game so feel free to comment also if
you're looking for the links for the
four different channels I'm going to be
going over in this video they're going
to be in the description below this
video so if you're like ah you know I
listened to what you said but I forgot
you know where do I go just click the
links below and you can get there from
the description so the first one is
online chess lessons this is william
stewart he does all the videos he is a
extremely talented national master this
is one of the newer channels on youtube
so just started out in 2011 but has some
of the greatest content that you're
going to find on youtube so again online
chess lessons he's going to be going
over a lot of commentary for some of the
more recent games if you kind of watched
my stuff i do a lot of you know
commentary for older games but if you're
always looking for new stuff new content
they are always updating this so online
chess lessons great great content the
next one is going to be Jerry at the
chest network probably one of the most
known guys out there probably one of the
nicest guys on YouTube that that I've
talked to extremely talented national
master as well very very strong when it
comes to blitz games something that I
really enjoyed watching him do but also
giving commentary on that so if you have
not heard of Jerry from the chest
network or gotten to talk to him before
definitely check out his channel
awesome stuff on here the next one is
going to be green castle block this is
matched channel he's been out there for
a long time and he just continues to put
solid stuff out there so again another
one of those channels that maybe a lot
of people haven't heard of but it has
been out there a long time and a ton of
ton of great content that you can go in
and find here and then lastly is King
crusher Kings crushers are not keen
crusher but kingscrusher another very
very talented player that puts a ton and
ton of content if you look at this
uploads 2500 videos so he's always
putting out content and he's one of the
strongest players that's actually
putting out content on YouTube so it's
awesome some of the greatest chess minds
out there are really trying to help out
those people you know falling in love
with tres chess and getting better so
again kingscrusher really enjoy
greencastle Matt great guy Jerry at the
chest network and then lastly william
stewart online chess lessons some great
stuff again if you have any feedback
from me put the comments down a bunch of
people been asking about the the new
series that we have going on with cass
para versus deep blue the next few
videos are going to be out this week so
definitely look out for those and i will
see you guys in the next video thanks
for watching